we're here with women's Grand Master
Tata have Abraham Yoon tab what's it
gonna take for you to win your first
u.s. women's chess championship actually
a lot of work probably determination
maybe a little good luck and I know that
I talked to some other women and they
said they're only focused at the
tournament but you've mentioned that you
have to have a decent tournament to
qualify for the Olympiad is it gonna be
hard to block out those thoughts during
your games you've garnered the nickname
or at least the persona of the penguin
tell us how that came about
I'm sure that came about I just really
like them and I have a collection of
them and then I think people really
encourage it almost all the way them
playing here I played here many times
and you played them at some point does
it become hard to generate new ideas
against the same women or does it
actually become a battle to see who
surprises the other ones most I think it
becomes both it becomes kind of you know
when you keep playing the same people
you just want to improve your score
against them or if you have a good score
you want to keep it but I think it gets
a little also a little tiresome keep
saying the same keep looking playing
same opening but at the same time it
just makes you work harder and try to
prove some things and you recently went
to a tournament near Paris is it are you
gonna go back to Europe and just do the
whole royal tour and playing a bunch of
events I would love to but just the
scheduling the finances
any chance I get to trouble my favorite
thing to do so I love see now how as
important is it to get off to a fast
start in an event like this well I think
is a round-robin it's yeah I think it's
kind of important because if you lose to
someone and then they start having a
good tournament then you're never gonna
catch up to them but in a Swiss you can
always catch up to people so it's kind
of what who you lose to how they do
continue doing because if you lose to
someone at some point and they don't do
so well that's okay but once you lose to
one of the leaders it's pretty much over
okay well good luck in trying to win
your first year that's great thanks
thanks